- [Narrator] Here's the G7,
a group of seven of the
world's advanced economies
including the US, UK, and Japan.
And here's what some call the alternative
from the developing world, the BRICS,
formed by Brazil, Russia,
India, China, and South Africa.
The BRICS is trying to
position itself as the voice
for emerging economies and
challenge western dominance
of global affairs.
Its leaders are holding
a summit in Johannesburg
to discuss an historic expansion.
More than 40 countries
including Saudi Arabia
and Iran want to join.
- The expansion of BRICS
could definitely boost the
group's global influence.
- [Narrator] Let's look
at what a potential enlargement
means for the alliance
and its ambitions to shake
up the global political
and economic order.
- The original term
BRIC was actually coined
by a Goldman Sachs banker,
grouping these really
different countries together
because they were so fast-growing.
- [Narrator] The leaders
of Brazil, Russia, India,
and China formalized their
relationship in 2009,
and invited South Africa to
join the alliance a year later.
- They decided to take
that idea in an effort
to create a bit of a political
and economic counterpoint
to what's perceived as
the western hegemony
of the global political
and economic spheres.
- [Narrator] The BRICS countries together
make up more more than 40%
of the world's population
and almost 1/3 of the world's GDP.
According to data from the
International Monetary Fund,
the bloc has already overtaken
the G7 nations' share
of the global economy
on the basis of purchasing power parity.
That's where the purchasing power
of different currencies is equalized.
Projections by Goldman Sachs
show the world's economic balance shifting
towards the BRICS and emerging economies.
China is expected to overtake the US
as the world's largest economy by 2050,
with India climbing to number three.
- China and India have
experienced massive growth
since the BRICS were founded in 2009,
and certainly have helped
them swell in importance
and remain relevant on the global stage.
- [Narrator] China and Russia
are pushing to enlarged BRICS.
Experts say Beijing is keen
to create an alternative
grouping to counter the US
and the west on the world stage.
- China has been bullish on
expanding BRICS for some time,
and they're particularly
keen at the moment
because of the trade tensions
with the US, the US looking
to diversify its supply
chains away from China.
- [Narrator] Russia sees an expansion
as a way to gain more international allies
following its full-scale
invasion of Ukraine.
(footsteps pattering)
South Africa publicly
supports the expansion,
as does Brazil, but experts
say behind the scenes,
Brazil and India want a
more measured approach.
- It seems that they are concerned
about the group leaning too autocratic,
so they want to have very
specific requirements
for admission to make sure
that there's a balance
amongst the members,
and that it doesn't become
sort of the autocratic G7.
- [Narrator] More than 20
countries have formally applied
to become part of BRICS,
ranging from Saudi Arabia
to Ethiopia, Argentina, and Indonesia.
Experts say Saudi Arabia
is a strong candidate
as a major economic and energy
power in the Middle East
with a growing role in regional diplomacy.
Indonesia with the world's
fourth largest population
is another strong contender.
- Indonesia being such a large economy
and important in the
electrification, clean energy tech,
electric vehicles, might
be a logical choice.
- [Narrator] One reason
for joining the BRICS
is gaining access to the
bloc's New Development Bank.
Since its founding in 2014,
the bank has approved more
than $30 billion in loans
for development and
infrastructure projects.
- Access to funding from this bank
which seemed to be having
more favorable terms
than a traditional development
bank like the World Bank
or the IMF is definitely
something that's attractive
to a lot of countries.
- [Narrator] The New
Development Bank also wants
to deepen the use of local currencies
instead of the US dollar
for trade and financing
between the BRICS nations.
Ultimately, experts say one
of the biggest challenges
for the BRICS to counter the
west is to form a united voice
on major global issues.
- Generally, the countries
have pretty diverse
and diverging interests in
politics, on security issues,
and even relations with the US.
I think the group would like to be seen
as an alternative political forum
to the G7 group of developed nations.
Whether or not it is able to achieve that,
I think will largely depend
on what countries it admits.
(bright music)